after months of anticipation dc fandom
has finally unveiled the first trailer
for mata reeves 2021 film the batman
this time out robert pattinson dons the
cape and cowl of the world's most famous
orphan turned vigilante as you'd expect
from a trailer as dense as this one it's
shocked full of small
easy to miss details and creepy clues
about the dark tidings ahead
recent films have strayed away from
batman's origins as a costume detective
however for this refresh matt reeves
take on batman seems poised to once
again fully
embrace the character's investigative
roots this should make this a very
different kind of batman movie
for starters paul dano's riddler appears
to be the film's primary antagonist
and this is a character whose whole
premise is based around riddles and
clues
hopefully this means that the film's
story will involve a complex mystery
which audiences will unravel alongside
the dark knight hidden within the
trailer there's a blink in your mystic
clue that could signify that pattinson's
bruce wayne
is about to have his entire world turned
sideways if true what happens over the
course of the batman could cause bruce
wayne to question everything
he's devoted himself to a trailer for
the batman opens on a grisly crime scene
a green jacketed killer presumably the
riddler has murdered gotham's mayor
bloody notes left behind by the killer
seem to link the mayor to lies
crime and corruption within gotham city
perhaps most importantly a small green
envelope has been left at the scene
it features one of the villains
trademark riddles scrolled onto a
greeting card
and a dress to the batman featured on
the front of the card is an owl with a
skeleton behind it perhaps in any other
superhero film you could write this up
as an in-joke or a random occurrence
in the batman though this is a detective
story after all
featuring the riddler as the main
villain so we suspect every single clue
matters the choice to feature an
owl on the card is almost certainly
intentional keep this in mind and pay
attention to how the trailer ends the
riddler has something important to say
to bruce wayne
how am i part of it
you'll see what does all this mean for
fans of the comics
it's easy to see how these two moments
could be linked even without knowing
exactly what riddler's endgame is
because owls have a special meaning in
gotham and the wayne family legacy might
not be as spotless as bruce wayne thinks
it is
bringing a new vision of batman to
today's audiences means confronting the
significant class issues inherent in
bruce wayne's origins
from a certain point of view bruce wayne
is an ultra privileged billionaire who
uses his wealth and power to beat
poor people instead of addressing
systemic inequalities at the source
so let's put a couple tables together
i'm not sure that they'll let us oh they
should
i own the place when examined closely
these issues seem to undermine batman's
entire crusade
a commentary brilliantly expressed in
sean murphy's white knight comics
based on this trailer it appears that
reeves won't shy away from the inherent
class conflict that defines batman
it seems this way because reeve's
version of gotham city looks like it has
an
owl problem i was looking over there for
a long time but i didn't see any
oh there they are gross but not just
anyhow
first introduced in 2011 the court of
vows is a secret society composed of
gotham's wealthiest and most powerful
families
when they meet they put on creepy owl
masks to obscure their identities
since the 1600s these families have
controlled gotham behind the scenes
they work to sustain a culture of crime
inequality
and corruption that makes gotham such an
infamously dangerous city to live in
to enforce their will the court of vows
uses orphaned children
trained as assassins and called talent
fortunately for bruce thomas and martha
wayne never joined this clandestine
group
in fact the comics depict them as
attacks with the court's conspiracies
however the wayne family's power and
influence are still inextricably linked
to the whole nightmare
one talon even believes that he's the
lost brother of bruce wayne
that brings us back to the riddler's
final words in the trailer if the
quarter vowels are indeed a part of the
batman's plot
pattinson's young vigilante hero is
about to have his entire world shaken to
its very foundation
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman
and dc fandom are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss
a single one